a múmia a tenho 26 anos e já trabalhou
klopp com a mãe
minha mãe falou que o concluiu o ensino
médio
eu queria muito normal que não tem
vontade que o caos está que eu não era
um estranho que só porque eu sou
diferente me acrescentar competição
normal na sociedade
eu gosto do meu toesca show que eu tenho
esse é o meu melhor com esse amigo
únicos cantou muito nervoso costa o
trabalho é esse eu eu tenho com meus fc
com meus colegas meus que me acalma é
muito companheiro sem eles eu não
coloquei fim precoce de mim
eu fiz um curso e sei que o coxa tem
muito que eu tava muito interesse ato
que porque quando ia na na festa na
palavra comum como a irmã eo irmão
costumava ficar feito o time titular tem
um interessante eu fiz um coiso o
interesse nessa aqui aprendi a ter um
teatro que eu gosto muito
gosto muito de fato e acreditei 'dança
te escolheu terapias gente ato eu tenho
meus amigos lá que é o único se também
que não tem mais nenhum amigo forte lá e
faz o discurso também em seat nagy
administrasse erro
eu gosto muito e piaçá campeão
tenho 48 e único time to
gostei muito tentar de ônibus sozinho
então também não tem um plantel de
ônibus táxi e ônibus ótimo fiquei muito
feliz
ian tá se tais rocinhas em minha mãe
oxum
ah o meu poder de escolha eu tenho um
canhoto ponte e tu e eu consigo chutar
depois que minha mão ea mãe ajuda a uma
mítica meus 1.500 de conca com as coisas
com a tanto no caso tanto muito se não
fosse os hoje por terminada a não gastar
com qualquer coisa no tempo no tse 582
fico muito feliz que eu tentei com os
dois até ter ganhado a chonqing miashita
que a entrada no mercado de trabalho se
não fossem a um que não ia ter com o
espírito e até hoje procurando emprego
então eu fui com a tristeza muito é só
um que me assaltou eu gosto capaz do que
em contato bencomo pressionou mais no
tempo essa coisa desse tipo à imprensa
tem tudo igual em cosmos se tiver frente
eu estou muito feliz e trabalhando pelo
quadro caótico sem capa num não me fez
entrar aparelho num eu nunca tive que
ficar em casa pra cá meu à minha frente
é só trabalho
aqui é uma palestra palestra porque eu
participei que minha mãe e confessou
participar de uma ong também que eu
gostei muito
o pessoal também encostou que eu tenho
a palestra tem o topo sob a minha fita
de ncapayi como eu como o meu trabalho
aqui é o peixoto teatro que chamou os
clientes amigos do pessoal também em
khost mim
sim eles só como já tinha falado de um
código e fé que são super gente fina que
é muito complicada longe a corte muito
esse topo é esse é a minha fita